when we are afraid of failing we come up
with a story about how it's not our
fault or how we're gonna do it in the
future
I've never lying down in the middle of
the road and I'm like right now
rise and shine it's expresso time what's
up believe nation it's Evan I believe in
you and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
let's start your day off right together
grab your coffee and sip on today's
message change your story over to you
tony robbins also if you want to know
what tony and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days i will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below the fact that
human beings are strongest drive is the
need to stay consistent with how we
define ourselves so while you're in this
passionate state that's where you make
decisions so if you want to change your
life my friends you've got to change
your physiology and you got to change
your focus
[Music]
how to do something is the wrong
sequence to start with like what's the
strategy for being fit and healthy it's
not that complex and yet 70% of the u.s.
is overweight like he doesn't have to do
it it's not a strategy problem but it is
is why are they doing it it's because
they have a story and everyone does is
entrepreneurs business people everyone
does this when we get fearful when we've
tried something that we're not
succeeding as fast as we want when we
are afraid of failing we come up with a
story about how it's not our fault or
how we're gonna do it in the future
because then we don't have to feel bad
feeling bad makes us have to deal with
it most people are overwhelm so they
just they come up with a story that I
tried everything
did you tried everything you'd be fit
you know I tried millions millions name
of three things they did any times that
don't work but I think if you can come
up when you change the story when you
come up with a new set of beliefs you'll
find yourself finding the strategy or
using the strategies that already work
that are there that right now your mind
says are won't work and the best way to
change people you got strategy story is
state and I only share this with disis
owners you've got to be able to produce
a different state in your people there
has to be something compelling there has
to be a sense of mission now I've got a
really special bonus clip for you that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
is time for a question of the day I want
to know what part of your story do you
need to change leave your answers in the
comments below
when I was at rock bottom I didn't know
that I was at rock bottom and you can't
really change what you're not aware of
and so it was like one of those things
where it's like can it get any worse
damn can it get any worse damn and it
just I kept asking the question can it
get any worse I didn't know that what I
was asking was causing my life so it was
to the point where either I die or I do
something about it because it was like I
didn't have my daughter pretty much was
like you're not my father you don't know
what love is my girlfriend had just
broke up with me and you know my mother
was pretty much she had 16 different was
it called met she was on 16 different
medications there was so much stuff
going on and I'm watching all of these
people be successful and I'm like I'm
more talented than them and I don't
understand why I'm still in the exact
same spot which I didn't know was rock
bottom and then it one day just all came
crashing down and I was like why am I
here I remember lying down in the middle
of the road and I'm like I wanna die
like right now and I stayed there cars
would drive them by honking and
everything and I don't know what
happened in between that but literally
my car had just got out of the impound
my mom had paid for it she didn't even
have much money but somehow she would
always do something for her baby boy and
she got much she got my car to the
impound a day I got my car to the
impound that's when somebody who broke
into my car like and it was like can it
get any worse that night on La Brea on
the corner of La Brea and Hollywood I'm
at the there's like this like little
shopping center and I car was parked my
window was busted out to the right and
and literally was raining was 343 in the
morning August 2011 and it was I yelled
out eyes bloodshot red and I still
didn't know that this was rock bottom
but I've always focused on what
don't want and I just remember say okay
okay I'm tired of fighting I don't want
to fight anymore I want to be healthy I
want to be happy I want to be surrounded
by nothing but positive people I just I
just want to inspire people and I want
to make a bunch of money but I want the
money to represent something that I
passionately believe it just show me a
sign show me a sign show me and I just
kept saying it over and over and over it
wasn't until a week later until I met
the man at the gas station and he asked
me for money and he said he said do you
have any money he's just like it was a
homeless guy and he had a wad of money I
say you have more money than me and he
goes if you ever seen the movie Rain Man
the guy was talking to himself person
did the exact same thing he was like
change our mindset change your life
change our mindset change your life
change our mindset change of life change
of mindset and then they walked away and
it was in that very moment I felt like
my whole entire life was a lie raise
your standard its core value not one
drop of my self-worth depends on your
it's something surreal if you want more
Tony check out the eight pieces of
life-changing advice video that I did on
him I think you're really gonna enjoy it
the link is right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there this is the greatest time to be
alive if you're growing you're learning
you're educating and you're developing
valuable skills